[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
les événements de cette nuit sont un
tournant dans l'histoire de l'europe et
de notre pays les sirènes dallaire
résonnent dans le centre ville de kiev
capitale de l'ukraine
il est 6h30 du matin heure locale place
maïdan le pays vient d'entrer en guerre
petit matin des chars russes ont franchi
la frontière de scène qui va entre la
biélorussie et l'ukraine au nord du pays
d'autres points de passage ont été
violées à la frontière est avec la
russie des camions militaires sont
également entrés dans le pays par la
crimée les républiques du dombass ont
appelé la russie à l'aide ce projet a
pour but j'ai décidé de mener une
opération militaire spéciale pour
protéger ces gens qui souffrent depuis
huit ans des abus et du génocide mené
par kiev heureusement nous savons que la
russie nous aide maintenant ça fait huit
ans que l'on vit sous les bombardements
ukrainien huit ans qu on risque notre
vie pour cela nous nous efforcerons de
démilitariser et 2d nazifié l'ukraine et
de traduire en justice ceux qui ont
commis de multiples crimes sanglants
contre des civils y compris des citoyens
russes nous avons déjà commencé à former
une coalition anti poutine j'ai déjà
exhorté les dirigeants mondiaux à
frapper poutine avec toutes les
sanctions possibles à offrir un soutien
de défense à grande échelle et à fermer
l'espace aérien au-dessus d'ukraine à
l'agresseur cette aventure barbare de
vladimir poutine doit cesser et doit
échouer je le dis au peuple russe dont
le président vient d'autoriser cette
vague de violence je le dis aux parts
ont des soldats qui vont perdre leur vie
dans cette guerre je sais que l'union
européenne en coordination avec les
états unis et le royaume uni s'accordent
dans les plus brefs délais sur les
sanctions les plus fermes des chars des
avions ont attaqué de toutes parts tôt
ce matin des explosions ont été entendus
jusque dans la capitale kiev et
milliards d'actifs amont précise ils
sont neuf cent mille côté russe 196
mille côté ukrainien président poutine
au nom de l'humanité
ramenez vos troupes en russie tout va
l'invasion russe en ukraine change le
cours de l'histoire en europe c'est une
évidence j'ai eu l'occasion de dire que
c'était un recul terrible ne permettons
pas le déplacement en europe de ce qui
pourrait être la pire guerre
depuis le début du siècle les
occidentaux ont une responsabilité dans
l'escaladé de la violence à l'est et
qu'ils doivent comprendre les
revendications russe contre l'expansion
de l'autre nous n'avons hélas rien fait
pour éviter cette escalade il faut
exclure les banques russes du système
switch d'échangés internationaux et puis
il faut que l'europe s'organise et
apporte les soutiens matériels y compris
militaires pour que les ukrainiennes et
les ukrainiens puisse se défendre et
cinq sont portées à la russie seront à
la hauteur de l'agression dont elle se
rend coupable sur le plan militaire et
économique autant que dans le domaine de
l'énergie nous serons sans faiblesse à
ceux qui tenteraient d'interférer avec
nous et plus encore de menacer notre
pays notre peuple ils doivent savoir que
la réponse de la russie sera immédiate
et conduire à des conséquences que vous
n'avez encore jamais connu nous allons
affaiblir l'économie russe
et sa capacité à se moderniser
nous allons geler les actifs russes au
sein de l'union européenne
and stop des axes et stopper l'accès des
banques russes au marché financier
européen
la chine suit de près la situation en
ukraine et appelle toutes les parties à
faire preuve de retenue pour éviter que
la situation ne devienne hors de
contrôle avec ses engagements il rend
aussi avec ses engagements personnels
qu'il fait avec des uns et les autres
c'est un cynique et c'est un dictateur